bon j'ai fini d'écrire de la première
version du manuscrit de mon livre j'ai
soumis à un éditeur qui l'ont ensuite
renvoyé à d'autres pères pour faire une
revue par les pairs pour avoir le retour
de d'autres scientifiques sur la qualité
de mon livre est malheureusement
l'éditeur a eu beaucoup de mal à trouver
des relecteurs suffisamment motivé pour
ce tu as pris mon livre et je comprends
tout à fait c'est un sacré pavé et aussi
beaucoup qui ont dit qu'ils n'étaient
pas suffisamment compétent pour lire
pour faire une revue de mon livre c'est
aussi je comprends tout à fait puisque
ce livre est extrêmement
interdisciplinaire et il ya quand même
pas mal de notions assez poussées qui
viennent de vous vers des domaines très
divers et variés qui vont de la
neuroscience philosophie épistémologie
en passant par le machine learning les
lois des probabilités et même la
physique théorique
ceci dit il y en avait quand même un qui
a été suffisamment motivé pour lire
quelques chapitre de mon livre et qui a
écrit no une revue à partir de 4 5
chapitres du livre qu'il avait lui et
malheureusement cette revue a été
négative et du coup l'éditeur a n'a pas
accepté de publier mon livre ce que je
comprends tout à fait alors le truc
c'est que du coup j'ai demandé à lire
cette revue est là j'ai été extrêmement
déçus voire complètement énervé voir
j'étais en fait complètement hors de moi
quand j'ai lu cette revue qui a été très
très très très critique
mais les arguments avancés pour être
critique pas en arriver à cette
conclusion que le livre ne devait pas
être publiées étaient incroyablement
disproportionnée par rapport à la
conclusion
de la revue pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée la plus grosse critiques
soulevées par cette revue était le fait
que dans le chapitre sur la logique au
moment où j'ai introduit la notion de où
je n'ai pas précisé s'il s'agissait d'un
ou inclus zifu d'un ou exclusifs et
d'après lui c'était une raison vraiment
fatale à la publication du livre
et ça ça m'a mis complètement hors de
moi je dire ce que j'avais écrit a été
ultra classique en logique
hier tous les livres de logique fond ce
que ce que j'avais fait et du coup
j'étais incroyablement énervé par par ce
réacteur et j'ai commencé à écrire un
email mais vraiment très très un mode
vénère va j'étais en mode hooligans
j'étais en mode incontrôlable j'étais
juste ultra énervé et bon heureusement -
heureusement j'ai pris conscience et à
quel point j'étais énervé du coup j'ai
embrayé d'abord ce que je comptais
écrire je vais d'abord envoyé des amis
qui ont ensuite dit qu'elle me toile et
en grèce annoncera à rien de faire ce
que tu as fait et grâce à eux j'ai
réussi à ne pas envoyer cette email
très très énervé que j'avais préparé
ok donc ça c'était en 2010 est donc
c'était le délai de 2010 est qui qui
était tout à coup le trailer des caisses
que je lui dirai si je pouvais rentrer
s'il faut affronter l'an passé et parler
à mon mois de 2010 est
et bien je lui dirai que sa déception
est totalement justifié il espérait il
s'attendait à être être publié il n'a
pas été publié et je pense que sa
déception est tout à fait légitime
en revanche je pense que sa colère n'est
absolument pas et qui n'aurait pas dû
être en colère et plus précisément je
lui dirai que la raison pour laquelle
ils étaient en colère c'est parce que
son idéologie a débordé sur sa
description du monde et sur sa vision du
monde tel qu'il est et ça je pense que
c'est un problème très très générale qui
est extrêmement problématique c'est le
fait que la manière dont on pense que le
monde devrait être a tendance à déborder
de façon irrationnelle sur ce que l'on
pense que le monde et c'est ce que je
pourrais appeler la guillotine inversée
'document la guillotine d'opium dit
qu'on peut pas déduire un devraient être
des 100 axiome morale additionnel et ça
c'est vraiment que je pense est
extrêmement important mais je pense
qu'un point qui est tout aussi important
c'est du coup ce que j'appelle ici
règles yotine inversée de tubes et qui
est malheureusement un des défauts que
l'on a souvent dans la manière dont on
débat qui vient du fait que on a
tendance à laisser déborder notre vision
du monde tel qu'il devrait être dire
notre idéologie sur notre vision du
monde et c'est à dire la description que
l'on a du monde tel qu'il est alors
petite précision cette guillotine
inversé il faut apprendre avec un petit
peu plus de soin c'est un peu plus
subtil que ça puisque j'ai certes
certains manière de la vision du monde
que tel qu'il devrait être que l'on a va
influencer les actions que l'on va
entreprendre qui peut du coup influencé
le monde tel qu'il est donc il ya un
lien entre le devrait être élu est
cependant pour que ce devrait être
affecte le monde tel qu'il est il semble
indispensable qu'il y ait une action
intermédiaire et que du coup sans action
le devrait être ne devrait pas
influencer en tout cas pas directement
le monde tel qu'il est ou plus
exactement notre vision du monde tel
qu'il est notre description du monde et
donc c'est quelque chose auquel je pense
qu'on ne prête pas assez attention et
invitera à faire plus attention à ça
pour une fois que vous serez dans un
débat est ce que finalement votre vision
du monde tel qu'il devra être n'est pas
en train de changer votre façon
d'analyser les données que vous avez du
monde tel qu'il est et du coup est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas en train de faire un
sophisme d'une guillotine 'document
inverser ça peut être intéressant en
tout cas de vous poser ce genre de
questions régulièrement notamment où
vous débattez et en particulier semble
que bien souvent la raison pour laquelle
on s'énerve c'est parce que on observe
une disjonction assez importante entente
entre le monde tel qu'il est tu as
composé ferrer tel qu'il est avec les
dernières données auxquelles on a accès
et la vision du monde tel qu'il devrait
être que l'on a c'est à dire notre
idéologie d'une certaine manière et
c'est cette tension entre l'idéologie et
le monde tel qu'il est qui est souvent
la cause de beaucoup d'énervement et
d'agacement une bonne façon d'éviter cet
agacement cet énervement
c'est de se dire tout simplement que le
monde tel qu'il est n'a pas de raison
d'être le monde tel qu'il devrait être
le monde tel qu'il est il est tel qu'il
est et le monde tel qu'il est deviendra
est très très bas c'est vous qui
l'imaginé ça peut être utile à avoir en
tête pour essayer de savoir vers quoi
attendre
comment modifier le monde pour qu'il
soit meilleur mais ça ne doit pas être
une raison d'agacement puisque le monde
n'a pas été construit pour qu'il soit
tel qu'il devrait être selon vous avant
de conclure cette vidéo j'aimerais dire
que tout ça est fortement influencé d'un
excellent livre que j'ai lu récemment
que j'ai écouté plus tôt qui est le
livre feeling good
de david byrne donc il ya des études qui
montrent que les personnes en troubles
qui ont des troubles mentaux notamment
de dépression pour ces personnes-là la
bibliothérapie c'est à dire le simple
fait de lire ce livre un effet
thérapeutique extrêmement important de
l'effet placebo et du coup je recommande
très très très vivement ses livres à
tous ceux parmi vous qui veulent se
sentir mieux typiquement parce que se
sont énervés comme moi comme le lait de
2017 par quelque chose qui m donc ce
livre est très intéressant vous pousse
pour se sentir mieux pour mieux
comprendre le monde et ne pas s'énerver
pour des mauvaises raisons mais ce livre
est également extrêmement intéressant et
c'est pour ça que j'ai lu d'un point de
vue le hashtag des bâtons mieux
puisqu'il ya beaucoup d'idées à
l'intérieur qui sont vraiment des idées
pour permettra de mieux réfléchir
collectivement et pour éviter des
mauvaises façons de débattre et et de
raisonner je recommande très vivement ce
livre dont on reparlera beaucoup dans
cette série débattons mieux et
d'ailleurs si vous voulez en savoir plus
sur ce livre sans le lire je recommande
cet ex en vidéo d'alexandre techno prog
qui on a fait une vidéo sur un des
aspects de ses livres